at dc fandom 2021 we finally got another
look at suicide squad kill the justice
league the next game from the team
behind the batman arkham series
rocksteady studios here's everything you
need to know about the upcoming co-op
action game for more on suicide squad
and gotham knights make sure to like
this video and subscribe
confusingly suicide squad is going to be
a continuation of the arkham games while
wb montreal's gotham knights is set in a
completely different universe in the
latest suicide squad trailer that
debuted at dc fandom there were a bunch
of callbacks to the original arkham
games suicide squad takes place after
the events of arkham knight and
rocksteady co-founder and creative
director sefton hill has said that some
narrative threats established in that
trilogy will pick up in this game
even though the suicide squad was
introduced in arkham origins wb
montreal's oft maligned prequel in kill
the justice league brainiac has attacked
metropolis so task force x or suicide
squad leader amanda waller sends her
group of criminal misfits to the city to
take out the alpha target who is
revealed to be superman
under the mind controlled effects of
brainiac we also see green lantern flash
and wonder woman which accounts for four
of the founding members of the league
although we see a car with batman symbol
on it the dark knight doesn't actually
show up which makes sense because
canonically speaking he's supposed to be
dead
or at least that's what he wants the
world to think
the four playable members of the suicide
squad are harley quinn deadshot captain
boomerang and everyone's favorite king
shark harley quinn will sound familiar
to anyone who's played arkham city or
knight as voice actress tara strong is
reprising her role we last saw harley
getting locked up at the end of arkham
knight so it's possible that task force
x leader amanda waller sprung her for
this job the trailer does begin with a
trip to arkham asylum after all she gets
around with a grapple and has her
signature baseball bat in hand we've
also had a run run-in with deadshot in
the arkham games he was hired by hugo
strange in arkham city to assassinate
political targets inside the place and
there was a side mission where you
captured him he was arrested by gcpd and
then later freed but they kept his
equipment king shark also has a very
recognizable voice he's played by wwe
wrestler samoa joe suicide squad
mastermind amanda waller will be calling
the shots while waller did appear in
arkham origins and arkham origins
blackgate she's now being voiced by
deborah wilson who you might recognize
from jedi following order or telltale's
batman we also caught a look at what
looks like gizmo in the latest trailer
he's a tinkerer that usually has run-ins
with the teen titans but seems to be
appearing in suicide squad to act as a
sort of cue for the squad in terms of
enemies brainiac is the big bad we've
seen so far invading metropolis and
bending superman's will to his own
ironically this isn't exactly the first
time we've seen this play out in recent
games superman turned evil in the first
injustice and in the sequel everyone
teamed up against brainiac we've also
caught a glimpse of the flash and green
lantern who are clearly all under
brainiac's spell
however it seems like wonder woman may
have escaped the same fate as she can be
seen fighting superman in some blink and
you'll miss it moments the penguin also
seems to have some sort of run-in with
the squad but it's not clear yet if he
was a metropolis on business
or if the game takes us to gotham city
suicide squad can be played in four
player drop-in dropout online co-op if
you fancy playing it alone the other
members of the squad will be controlled
by ai and you can switch between them at
will as i mentioned earlier suicide
squad killed the justice league is being
made by rocksteady studios who are most
famous for the arkham games asylum city
knight and vr it's been a long time
since we've seen a new release from them
as arkham knight was in 2015 and vr
followed in 2016.
in terms of key developers working on
the game it looks like arkham director
sefton hill is on board as creative
director
suicide squad killed the justice league
will launch on pc xbox series x s and
playstation 5 in 2022
[Music]
you